now some very very sketchy details  reaching us here at sky center important  enough to bring to you though at this  early stage we believe that a plane has  crashed into the World Trade Center in  New York that happened within the last  few moments no details at this stage as  to what sort of plane it is it could  well be a large plane we are hearing  reports of a 737 not yet confirmed yet  although it is a jet more as we have it  let's have a look what CBS News is  saying our colleagues over in America  tip of Manhattan you're looking at the  World Trade Center we understand that a  plane has crashed into the World Trade  Center we don't know anything more than  that we don't know if it was a  commercial aircraft we don't know if it  was a private aircraft we have no idea  how many were on board or what is what  the extent of the injuries are right now